a large gathering of family and friends
apart from many we loved but i hope you
had a good thanksgiving
and i know times are tough but i want
you to know that help
is on the way last week i announced the
nominations and staff for critical
foreign policy
and national security positions a
first-rate team
that's going to keep us safe and secure
and today
i have the pleasure of the pleasure of
announcing key nominations and
appointments for the critical economic
positions in the administration
a first-rate team that's going to get us
through this ongoing economic crisis
it was before a team that's tested and
experienced
it includes groundbreaking amer
relief here in the united states of
america
and given a fair shot and an equal
chance
there's nothing we all believe there's
nothing beyond the capacity
of the american people let's not forget
who built this country working class and
middle class people built this country
and unions built the middle class
and from the most unequal economic and
job crisis in modern history
we can build a new american economy that
works for all
americans not just some all we need to
act now though
and we need to work together you know in
the weeks since
winning the election vice president
harris and i
have uh covered meetings with uh
a number convenience with liberators
and ceos at the same time mayors and
governors of both political parties
there's a consensus out there that as we
battle the covet 19 disease
we have to make sure that business and
workers have the tools resources and
guidance
and the health and safety standards to
be able to operate safely
the goal is simple to keep businesses
and schools
open safely and for millions of
americans who have lost their jobs or
hours
and have had to claim unemployment we
have to deliver them
immediate relief that includes
affordable health care
for millions of people who have lost it
and are in danger of losing it
child care sick leave family leave so
workers don't have to choose between
work and family
relief from rent and student loans
we need to support small businesses and
entrepreneurs
who form the backbone of the communities
that we live in
that are teetering on the edge you know
there's an urgent need to fund state and
cities
so they can the front line workers on
those jobs can stay in the jobs
you know the founders are pretty smart i
could have gotten this lesson from the
future secretary of the treasury
you know there's a reason why all the
states and localities have to have a
balanced budget but we're allowed
federally
to run a deficit in order to deal with
crises and emergencies that we have in
the past
and we have to keep vital public
services running
we have to give aid to local and state
governments
to make sure they can have law
enforcement officers firefighters
educators
as we did in the recovery act of 2009
and right now the full congress should
come together and pass a robust package
for relief
to address these urgent needs but any
package
passed in a lame duck session is likely
to be at best
just a start my transition team is
already working on
what i'll put forward in the next
congress to address the multiple
crises we're facing especially our
economic
and covert crisis and the team i'm
announcing today
will play a critical role in shaping our
plan for action
starting on day one and move fast to
revive this economy
they're going to help me help us to help
the country
lay out my build back better plan a plan
that an independent analysis from
moody's a well-respected wall street
firm projected
would create 18.6 million jobs
it's based on a simple proposition
reward
hard work in america not wealth
it's time to invest in infrastructure
clean energy climate change
manufacturing and so much more
that will create millions of good paying
jobs
this time we address the structural
inequities in our economy
that this pandemic has laid bare
economists call this current economy
and recovery k-shaped well
like the two lines coming off of a k
some people
some people are seeing their prospects
soar upward while others
are watching their economic prospects
dropped sharply
for those at the top jobs have come back
their wealth is rising
for example luxury home sales are up
over 40 percent
compared to last year
the top jobs have come back their wealth
is rising
for example luxury home sales are up
over 40
compared to last year but from those in
the middle and the bottom
it's a downward slide they're left
figuring out how to pay the bills and
put food on the table
almost one in every six renters was
behind in rent payments
as of october let me be clear
with this team and others we'll add
in the weeks ahead that we're going to
create a recovery for everybody
for all we're going to get this economy
moving again
we're going to create jobs raise incomes
reduce drug prices advance racial
equity across the economy and restore
the backbone of this country
the middle class our message to
everybody's struggling right now is this
help is on the way my dad
you've heard me say this before when he
lost his job in scranton
when i was a kid and we eventually moved
the family not far from here claim on
delaware
just an outskirts of wilmington he used
to say joey
a job is about a lot more than a
paycheck it's about your dignity
it's about respect your place in the
community
it's about being able to look your kid
in the eye and say honey it's gonna be
okay
and mean it i also used to say
joey i don't expect the government to
solve my problems
but i do expect them to understand my
problems
this team understands for secretary of
treasury i am
really pleased to be able to nominate
janet yellen
no one is better prepared to deal with
these crisis
i wish it weren't as much of a crisis
future secretary
but she'll be the first treasury
secretary who was also
chair of the federal reserve vice chair
of the federal reserve
and chair of the president's council of
economic advisers
janet is one of the most important
economic thinkers of our time
she's spent her career focused on
unemployment
and the dignity of work which is really
important to me
and to all of us she understands what it
means
to people and their communities when
they have good decent jobs
respect across being looked at by their
neighbors and being respected it matters
a lot to me
and respected across party lines and
around the world
by main street and wall street an
educator
a mentor above all the daughter of a
working class
from a working-class brooklyn
neighborhood who never forgot where she
came from
her husband george is pretty good too
he's won a nobel prize but he's the one
that married up
[Laughter]
janet will be are you the first woman to
hold this office
we might have to uh ask uh lin-manuel
miranda who wrote the musical about the
first secretary treasury hamilton
to write another musical about the first
woman secretary of the treasury yellen
so that's what i'm working on right now
janet
for director of office of managing the
budget i nominate
neri tandon you know i've known near a
long time
a brilliant policy mind with critical
practical experience
across government she was raised by a
single mom
on food stamps an immigrant from india
whose struggle worked hard
and did everything she could for her
daughter to live out
the american dream and nura did just
that
she understands the struggles that
millions of americans are facing
and should be the first woman of color
from south asia
from south asia excuse me from south
asia
and uh and i think that uh to lead omb
we also have another one of those women
whose vice president united states
america
and so look all being very serious
she'll be in charge of laying out the
budget that will help us control the
virus
and deal with the economic crisis and
build back better but above all she
believes what i believe
a budget should reflect our values
again quoting my dad for real my dad's
people would say joe let me tell you
what i value
and they look at them as a high school
educated guy very well read
and they look at me and say don't tell
me much about you show me your budget
i'll tell you what you value
that's what you're going to do for us as
deputy secretary of treasury i nominate
wally artierno wally is uh
um you know wally i don't know uh
i tell you what senator warren really
likes you
she highly recommended you but i wasn't
sure she worried i stole you as well but
thank you for being willing to do this
wally a skilled leader and think around
issues ranging from
macroeconomics to consumer protection
and from national security international
affairs
i've worked with wally during the great
recession that was my excuse to the
senator saying that's why i wanted to
steal you
and i saw him tackle one big job after
another
deputy national security adviser to
president obama
deputy director for the national
economic council
former chief of staff to elizabeth
warren where he helped create the
consumer protection bureau
and financial bureau which has done so
much good
it's designed to protect consumers and
working people from unfair deceptive and
abusive financial practices
and now wally will be the first african
american ever to hold this post
and the highest ranking african-american
in the treasury department sister
an immigrant from nigeria a son of a
nurse and an elementary school principal
wally understands everything we do is
basically for
the people for families hard-working
people
to understand their struggles and most
of all their dreams
and he understands both i want to thank
you wally for
being willing to do this for chairperson
of council economic advisors
i nominate notwithstanding she was a
very distinguished professor
at princeton i joke my my children who
went to penn
used to always kid about you know
but cecilia cece rouse one of the most
distinguished economists in the country
an expert on labor economics and race
poverty and education
dean of the princeton school of public
and international affairs
a member of the council of economic
advisers to president obama
adviser to president clinton at the
national economic council
more than that she's a proud daughter
whose mom a school psychologist
encouraged her to
pursue her pursue economics and her dad
one of the country's first
african-american astrophysicists
who dared her to dream she's done both
if confirmed cece will be the first let
me excuse me the fourth
woman to lead the council of national
outcome of economic advisers
and the first african-american ever to
hold that post
and as cea chair she'll serve as a
member of my cabinet
as well as a member of the council of
economic advisors we also appoint jared
bernstein an old friend who's been with
me a long time a brilliant thinker
a quick quick wit with the heart as big
as his head
and a heart he got from his mom an
educator who raised him correctly
a social worker turned economist jared
is one of my closest economic advisors
and friend he served as my chief
economist during the vice presidency
he was there in that foxhole during the
great recession
with the economy on the brink and our
country on our back
i couldn't think of anyone else who i'd
want to be in my side
to face the challenges ahead jared will
be one of the leading voices in my
administration on economic policy
i can always count on him to deliver
straight from the shoulder
as his hero fdr used to say straight
from the shoulder
the one thing i can assure is working
people will always have a voice
with jared and this council
as a member of the council economic
advisors i appoint
heather bousai heather uh thank you for
all the help you had
in the transition team and getting me
here she's
one of the foremost economists working
to make a sure we
build an economy that works for all
americans
the daughter of a union family it's no
wonder she believes so deeply in the
idea
that uh leave no one out leave no one
behind
in this economy during the campaign i
relied on our council on addressing
structural inequities within the economy
and i'll do so again as president
because the center that's one of the
central issues of our time
to this team thank you for accepting the
call to serve again
your uh to your families and to your
uh thank them for their sacrifices
because there's real sacrifice
we could not do this without you and to
the american people
this team will always be there for you
and your families
this is family oriented team
we got to make sure ordinary people get
a chance to do well because they've
never
when given a chance they've never ever
ever ever let the country down
eleven years ago president obama and i
entered office during the great
recession
and implemented the recovery act and
saved us from a great depression
i didn't see the map of america at the
time
nor did he in terms of blue states and
red states
we only saw the united states america we
worked with everyone
for everyone and we recovered and
rebuilt
together as one nation vice president
harris and i
will do that all over again with an
outstanding team
they're ready on day one to the united
states senate
i hope those outstanding these
outstanding nominees will receive a
prompt hearing
and that we will be able to work across
the aisle in good faith
and move forward as one country so let's
begin the work
to heal to unite to rebuild an economy
for all americans they deserve and
expect
nothing less thank you may god bless you
and may god protect our troops i now
turn this over to the new team
starting with our next secretary of
treasury
janet yellen again janet thanks for
accepting
appreciate it i think they're going to
clean this off for us here
thank you mr president-elect and madam
vice president-elect
it's my great honor to have this
opportunity to serve you
and the american people and to join this
incredible economic team
at this moment of great challenge for
our country
mr president-elect when you reflect on
what your father
taught you about how a job is much more
than a paycheck
i hear my own father who raised our
family
in working class brooklyn when he
graduated from medical school during the
great depression
he looked for a home and a place to hang
his shingle
near the brooklyn docks back then
bush terminal on the upper new york bay
was a thriving hub for manufacturing and
transportation
and for the union workers whose
livelihoods depended on them
knowing they didn't have cars my father
found a home near a bus
line he started his family practice in
the basement
while we lived on the floors above
at the end of the day he would talk to
me
my brother and my mom about what work
meant to his patients our friends and
neighbors
especially if they lost a job the
financial problems
the family problems the health problems
the loss of dignity and self-worth
the value of work always stuck with me
so much so that i became an economist
because i was concerned about the tool
of unemployment on people
families and communities
and i've spent my career trying to make
sure people can work
and achieve the dignity and self-worth
that comes with it
mr president-elect i know you've done
the same
i saw that understanding during the last
great recession
and the recovery act that followed
and now we're facing historic crises
again
the pandemic and economic fallout fit
together
have caused so much damage for so many
and have had a disproportionate impact
on the most
vulnerable among us lost
lives lost jobs small businesses
struggling to stay alive or closed for
good
so many people struggling to put food on
the table
and pay bills and rent it's an american
tragedy and it's essential that we move
with
urgency inaction will reduce
a self-enforcing downturn
causing more devastation
and we miss we risk missing the
obligation
to address deeper structural problems
inequality
stagnant wages especially for workers
who lack a college education
communities that have seen industry
disappear
with no good jobs replacing lost ones
racial disparities in pay job
opportunities
housing food security and small business
lending that deny wealth building
to communities of color gender
disparities
that keep women out of the workforce and
keep our economy from running
at full force it's a convergence of
tragedies
that is not only economically
unsustainable
but one that betrays our commitment to
giving
every american an equal chance to get
ahead
but i know this team will never give up
that commitment
as you've said before mr president-elect
out of our collective pain as a nation
we will find collective purpose to
control the pandemic
and build our economy back better than
before
to rebuild our infrastructure and create
better jobs
to invest in our workforce to advance
racial equity
and make sure the economic recovery
includes everyone
to address the climate crisis with
american ingenuity
and american jobs working together with
the outstanding national
security and foreign policy team you
announced last week
to help restore america's global
leadership
and above all we share your belief in
the american dream
of a society where each person with
effort
can rise to their potential and dream
even bigger for their children
i pledge as treasury secretary
to work every day towards rebuilding
that dream for all
americans and to the great public
servants of the treasury department
i look forward to working with you and
wally to rebuild the public trust
to the american people we will be an
institution that wakes up every morning
thinking about you your jobs
your paychecks your struggles
your hopes your dignity and your
limitless potential
thank you thank you
so
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
i'm humbled and honored by the trust
you've placed in me
to work with this talented team on
behalf of the american people
i'm especially proud to work alongside
leaders who understand
that budgets are not abstractions they
are a reflection of our values
they touch our lives in profound ways
and sometimes they make all the
difference
like the vice president-elect's mother
shamala my mother maya
was born in india like so many millions
across
every generation she came to america to
pursue a better life
i was raised in a suburb of boston a
middle-class kid
but when i was five my parents got
divorced
and my mom was left on her own with two
young children
and without a job she faced a choice
returned to india where at a time
divorce was stigmatized
and the opportunities for her and her
children would be limited
or keep fighting for her
american dream she stayed
and america came through for her when
times were tough we relied on food
stamps to eat
we relied on section 8 housing vouchers
to pay the rent
we relied on the social net safety net
to get back on our feet
this country gave her a fair shot
to reach the middle class and she made
it work
she got a job as a travel agent and
before long
she was able to buy us her own home in
medford massachusetts
and eventually see her children off to
college
and beyond i'm here today
thanks to my mother's brit but also
thanks to a country that had faith in us
is that invested in her humanity and
in our dreams i'm here today
because of social programs because
of budgetary choices because of a
government
that saw my mother's dignity
and gave her a chance now it is my
profound honor to help shape those
budgets and programs to keep lifting
americans
up to pull families back from the brink
to give everybody the fair
chance my mom got and that every single
person deserves
that's the america maya and shamila were
drawn to
the america the president-elect and vice
president-elect
are ready to grow i believe so
strongly that our government is meant to
serve all the american people
republicans democrats and independents
alike
all of whom deserve to know their
government has their back
i look forward to working together
alongside the dedicated career
professionals of the omb
to expand possibilities for every
american family
and i want to thank my own wonderful
family my husband ben
without his love and support i would
simply not be her
and our children alina and jaden thank
you all
for this profound opportunity to serve
mr president-elect madam vice
president-elect
thank you for this profound opportunity
to return to the treasury department
and serve the american people i know
firsthand the president-elect's capacity
to lift our country out of
our times because i had the privilege of
working with him to help
americans recover from the great
recession
in california's inland empire where i
grown up
in a working-class neighborhood the
great recession hit us hard
we were one of the foreclosure capitals
in the united states
the pain of this was real for me it
wasn't just numbers in a report
or stories on the nightly news but
neighbors and friends
who lost everything i was proud of the
work i got to do with the consumer
financial protection bureau
protecting american consumers at the
treasury department helping to grow the
us economy
i was proud also of getting a chance to
serve with leaders like the
president-elect
who oversaw the recovery act
implementation
investing in american workers betting on
their resilience and drive
and giving families a chance to get up
off the mat
i believe that's what public service is
all about at its best
giving people a fair shot when they need
it most
offering hope through the dark times and
making sure that our economy works
not just for the wealthy but for the
hard working people who make it run
those are lessons i learned from my
parents an elementary school principal
and a nurse
who came to america to build a better
life for me and my siblings
they taught us that we have a
responsibility to serve our community
and the country that gave us so many
opportunities
but i also learned early on how much
more needs to be done
to ensure that everyone has a fair
chance they deserve
i look forward to working with janet
yellen to reduce inequality in this
country and expand the middle class
and make sure that we build an economy
that works for everyone
and as we build back better we must also
remain laser focused on the treasury
department's
critical role protecting our national
security this
includes using our sanctions regime to
hold bad actors accountable
dismantling the financial networks of
terrorist organizations
and others who seek to do us harm and
ensuring our foreign investment policy
protects america's national security
interests
the challenges before us today are
unlike anything we have ever faced
but i know that what the president-elect
so often reminds us of
is true the american people can do
anything
when given a chance and i'm honored to
be a part of this talented team
and to work with them and all the
american people to build an economy that
gives everyone that chance
and turns our nation once again from
crisis to hope
thank you
good afternoon mr president-elect
madam vice president-elect thank you for
this extraordinary opportunity to join
this team
i'm humbled and honored and ready to get
to work for the american people
to be perfectly honest until recently i
did not anticipate
i would return to public service
as every academic knows when you've laid
down roots at a school you love
with incredible students and colleagues
you've grown with
it isn't easy to take a leave it
requires a rare combination of
urgency and opportunity to pull you away
but that rare combination is precisely
what our nation is facing right now
my path as an economist began in my
first year of college
my mother the school psychologist
encouraged me to take a course in
economics
and it happened to coincide with what at
the time was one of the worst spikes in
unemployment since the great depression
it was impossible for me to separate
what we were learning in the classroom
from what i know was going on in towns
across the country
and so i found myself drawn to the study
of the labor market
in all of its dimensions the reasons
that jobs disappear
the impact of education on people's job
prospects
and the ways we can tear down barriers
to job growth
and make it easier for people to find
long-lasting economic security
today nearly 40 years later we are once
again living through
one of the worst job crises since the
great depression
millions of families have had their
lives turned upside down
the safety net has frayed leaving
vulnerable americans to slip through
into hardship and hopelessness
and importantly structural inequities
that have always existed in our economy
are being exacerbated like never before
this is a moment of urgency and
opportunity
unlike any we face in modern times the
urgency of ending a devastating crisis
and the opportunity to build a better
economy in its wake
an economy that works for everyone
brings fulfilling job opportunities
and leaves no one to fall through the
cracks
i look forward to working with the
president-elect and vice president-elect
and this amazing entire economic team
to address that urgency and seize that
opportunity
and make our economic system work better
for every american
thank you
[Music]
good um i'm
hard pressed to find the words to
express my gratitude to the
president-elect and vice president-elect
for the chance to be here today in
thinking about the path that brought me
here a good place to start
is 12 years ago almost to the day
when i met with then vice
president-elect biden
at his home not far from here it was
supposed to be a job
interview to be his chief economist but
it quickly turned into a conversation
about economic justice and fairness
which as many here know
is a common destination in conversations
with president-elect
over the years we've continued that
discussion
often it takes the form of some policy
minutiae
sometimes it's me hitting him with far
more graphics than are necessary
or him telling me to stop speaking
economies and start speaking english
guilty as charged mr president-elect
i suspect the reason we had such a
meeting of the minds back then
dates back to a common saying in my
household when i was growing up
if you're not part of the solution
you're part of the problem
i grew up with a single mother a
lifelong educator
there was a picture of fdr on the wall
her proudest moment wasn't when i got a
phd
it was when i got a union card local 802
the new york city's musicians union but
that's a whole other story
of course if you intend to be part of
the solution you need to
accurately diagnose the problem in that
regard i think the president and vice
president-elect's agenda
is timely resident and visionary
yes they've stressed the urgent need to
control the virus and provide the relief
needed
to help families and businesses get to
the other side of this crisis
but they've been just as adamant that
simply getting back to where we were
sets the bar too low we must build back
an economy that's far more resilient
far more fair and far more inclusive
it is precisely the vision this nation
needs
and i suspect i'm not the only person on
this stage
chomping at the bit to get to work on
making their vision a reality
thank you
mr president-elect and madam
vice president-elect i am honored
and very grateful for the chance to be a
part of this
absolutely exceptional team and excited
to get to work
helping build an economy rooted in the
values that we share
equality opportunity and the dignity of
work
it's no accident that i've focused my
career on instilling those values in our
economy
developing policies that help our nation
grow stronger by growing more equitably
like the president-elect and the vice
president-elect those values were
instilled in me
at a young age in the late 1970s
my dad got a job at boeing and if you
grew up in seattle like i did
you know what that means a lot more than
a paycheck
as janet referenced and as the president
so often reminds us
and for our family my dad's job at
boeing
meant security it meant union benefits
a place in the neighborhood a place in
the middle class
but when the recession hit in the early
1980s
one by one the pink slips arrived for
every family in our cul-de-sac
every kid at my bus stop who had a
parent who was laid off
our entire community saw its future
dimmed and one by one
it was my turn so the first time i truly
experienced this thing
called the economy it was my parents
sitting down and explaining that things
were going to be tougher for a while
because my dad was on layoff too many
kids in america
experience the economy through those
kinds of difficult conversations
or far worse i was struck
by the profound power this mysterious
force held over my life
my friends and my community and i
wondered if that power
couldn't also be wielded to create
happier conversations
and fuller lives i've dedicated my
career to figuring out how we can grow
and sustain the middle class
and uproot the gender barriers and
racial barriers that leave too many
americans
outside the dream looking in through the
organization i co-founded
i've pursued solutions to reverse the
dangerous march of inequality
and bring us back to the core value of
broadly shared success
that's the same value i see at the heart
of the build back better plan
and why it's i'm then why i'm so excited
and honored
to help this team bring not just good
jobs but the good lives
and peace of mind that comes with them
to every american community
thank you
mr president-elect congratulations on
choosing this
outstanding team of brilliant minds
this economic team this is the right
team for this moment
and to our nominees and appointees thank
you
for your continued service to our nation
this is the team we need to deliver
immediate
economic relief to the american people
to get our economy back on track and to
make sure
it works for working people
and as president-elect biden noted
earlier
completing that task could not be more
urgent
cases of covid19 are spiking and beyond
the tragic loss of life
the toll of this recession continues to
mount
across america one in six adults with
children say their families are
hungry janet yellen talked about food
insecurity this is real we are looking
at a hunger crisis in america right now
one in three adults are having trouble
paying their bills
essential bills the bills that need to
be paid at the end of
every month to get to the next month
and the number of open small businesses
has fallen by nearly 30 percent
due to this pandemic while many others
are hoping they can stay afloat
until a vaccine is available these are
the struggles
the worries that keep people up in the
middle of the night
that have them sitting at their kitchen
table past midnight
trying to figure out how they're going
to make it work
but americans are not united by their
worries
alone they are also united by their
aspirations
the aspirations they have for themselves
for their children
for their families and for their
community
because no matter where you live or what
language your grandmother speaks
everyone wants to be able to get a job
and keep a job no matter what your
gender
or who you love everyone wants to be
able to buy a home
and keep a home and no matter how you
worship or who you voted for in this
election
everyone wants to be able to give their
children
a decent education and allow those
children to pursue
their dreams even during a pandemic
and joe and i understand that we were
raised
to respect the dignity of work we were
raised
by hard-working parents who always
understood the dignity of work
and the potential not only for their
children
but of our country and that's why i've
always fought for working people
standing up for middle class families
who'd lost their homes
in the great recession you talked about
that
families in california were devastated
but
they were able to rely on their
government
and the leaders as joe always talks
about who needed to see their condition
and speak to that condition and that's
the work that needs to happen now
and i look forward to collaborating with
this extraordinary team
to put working people front and center
in our administration these public
servants
are some of america's most brilliant
minds
they are proven leaders whose talents
achievements
and life stories their life stories
reflect
the stories of the american people and
their stories reflect
the very best of our country and they
not only have the experience
the expertise and what is necessary to
help
end this economic crisis but also what
is necessary to put people back to work
and they also share in our commitment
to building an economy and america
where everyone has access to a higher
minimum wage and affordable health care
paid family leave and paid sick leave
home ownership
and capital to start a small business
and america where opportunity is within
reach
for everyone for all
the people so we've got a lot of work to
do
to build that america and as joe always
says
to build back better and president-elect
biden and i
together with this economic team will be
ready to hit the ground
running on day one because that
is what this crisis demands and that
is what the american people deserve
thank you
all right you i am quick takes jennifer
zabasaja in new york you've just been
watching
quick takes coverage of president-elect
joe biden
introducing the nominations for his
economic team
and as you may have noticed it was a
team
full of historic firsts of course that
includes
janet yellen who becomes the first woman
to lead the u.s treasury if confirmed
as well as wally adeyamo his nominee to
serve
as deputy secretary who as the
president-elect said
came highly recommended from senator
elizabeth warren actually if confirmed
adayama would become the first
african-american
to hold that post biden also nominated
nira tandon placing her on track to
become the first woman of color
and first south asian american to lead
the omb
biden said that she'll be in charge of
laying out the budget to help
control the virus and you know he also
nominated cecilia rouse
to serve as the chair of the council of
economic advisers
if confirmed she would become the first
african american and the fourth woman
to lead the council and so what we
really heard from biden
is that this is a family oriented team
and we heard that from several members
of the team as well and this is a team
that understands the problems that
americans are going through
and as vice president-elect harris said
is